it's Friday September 16th and gamespot
Australia is out for the week so they've
handed the show over to us office I'm
Mike here your top five news stories
from this week if like me you thought
Pokemon go fever had finally subsided
you were wrong this week developer
niantic released an update to the
augmented reality game that allows one
of the Pokemon you've captured to be
your buddy this bunny can then help you
gather useful candies as you and your
digital avatar wander the streets of my
antics virtual hellscape covered as it
is in candy and outlandish creatures the
new update also fixes several minor
issues chief among them being a bug that
let your eggs hatch without receiving a
notification according to niantic you
should no longer miss out on the chance
to watch your Pokemon escape the
confines of their ovular prison cells
Capcom also delivered an update this
week this time to resident evil 7 bio
hazards beginning our demo the newly
named Twilight demo allows you to
explore more of the mansion we've come
to know since Capcom release beginning
our back in June furthermore the demo
continues to surge in popularity
garnering more than 3 million downloads
on ps4 raising the bar higher since it
broke the 2 million mark in early July
somehow though we still have no idea
what that mysterious finger does and if
you somehow still haven't gotten your
fill of updates this week don't worry
Sony's got you covered the company
released update 4.0 for the ps4
implementing numerous changes to the
council's interface and menu
functionality most notably it changes
how the quick menu works replacing the
full screen pop up with a tab that gives
you access to power options your friends
list and music playing capabilities
four-point-oh also adds HDR capability
to all ps4s however this doesn't exactly
matter yet because there's still no
content to support it here's looking at
the ps4 pro and it launches in November
in a recent interview with Rolling
Stones glick soul bioshock creator ken
Levine discussed the series of events
that drove him away from the iconic
franchise apart from logistical matters
that led to Levine studio irrational
being shuttered the designer also shared
personal reasons for leaving Bioshock
behind as Levine says development on
bioshock infinite had an adverse effect
on his life from his personal
relationships to his own health when
asked about his decision to move on to
other creative pursuits he said I think
the natural expectation was that I would
go and do the next bigger and
her bio shot game and I felt I think
I'll fail if I do that I think I'll lose
my mind and my marriage and so my
solution was to quit and what's probably
the weirdest news story of the week the
tail is emerge of a Miami man who
received an xbox one two weeks before
the console was ever even announced
apparently 25 year old Jiali had ordered
a new laptop and instead received a
prototype Xbox one that was stored at
the same shipping facility whether it
was a shipping label error or a problem
with Microsoft back-end Lee opened the
package to find a machine the general
public wouldn't even see for another two
weeks Microsoft soon sent a
representative to retrieve the console
and cover up the incident in what we
like to think was a men in black style
operation lady and gentlemen if you will
look right here so there you have it the
top 5 news stories from this week
between the updates to Pokemon go
resident evil 7 biohazard and your ps4
you should have plenty to keep you busy
until jess mcdonald is back here doing
top 5 next week until then